[Applause]
how you doing now uh is this starting
out live thing this is still pretty new
for you
this is yes this is very exciting this
must have been a dream of yours for a
long time yes yeah i was at the
groundlings in los angeles
doing improv out there another place and
uh how okay so your family must be
over the top crazy thrilled that you're
doing something live yeah they're
they're very excited it still hasn't
quite hit them i don't think that i'm
on the show when i actually have a job
right um i mean they watch it but they
sort of still can't believe it yeah like
when i when i
called my dad to tell him that i was
coming on your show i was like i'm so
excited i'm gonna be on conan oh my gosh
and he was like oh he's like that's so
great he's like for what
i was like um i'm gonna i'm gonna be a
guest on the show i know i can't believe
it he was like oh um
alone by yourself
why would they have you that's not right
your dad has to get behind this thing he
must be a big fan of conan huh
he loves you yeah that's great
uh who's this coney and o'brien anyway
that's on pretty late
uh now you started out in los angeles i
did the same thing i graduated from
college and i went right to los angeles
to try and get into show business
you started in la as well yes i um was
actually in school
in arizona and i moved to la kind of
quick decision i didn't tell my parents
i was leaving um
moving to l.a um so it's like you ran
away
no no i was in arizona and i just wanted
to go and i was scared to tell my
parents so i just didn't
um and then i went out there and i got a
job
at um the hollywood hot dog company the
hollywood
hot dog company what is the hollywood
hot is that like a hot dog stand
no it's it's a restaurant it was a
restaurant it's not there anymore but it
was in beverly hills
and it was like a little i'm surprised
it failed
it's a restaurant that's called the hot
dogs it was like gourmet hot dogs and
what's a gourmet hot dog i'm just
curious good
pork this hot dog is made with the
finest pork
do they like take it they open up a
little silver turin yes
wow incredible so uh and did people were
people excited for you working at the
hot dog company um
well the yeah rumors kind of went around
back home that i'd moved to l.a and that
i worked at a hot dog stand
in the city that i had my own hot dog
stand so i had to clear that up i was
like no it's
a it's a hot dog restaurant and it's
very
different you don't understand man they
have fancy sauces and john lovitz came
in once
fancy sauces yeah like a ketchup sauce
a sauce made of mustard seeds um
so you worked for a long time uh at this
restaurant and then you how did you like
break in did you
break in commercials um i i did do
some commercials i um because you know
when you move there you have to have
your head shot and your resume and my
resume was
was there was nothing on it it looked
like a flyer that's like just my name
and like two things
um well some people list all kinds of
skills on their resume when they want to
be an actor or a comedian they say
crossbow
you know good at running and i can i can
high dive things like that yeah but that
can also get you in trouble because
my it was my second commercial audition
and my agent called me and she said
she's like oh i got this audition came
in um but i need to know are are you a
dancer
right and i was like uh yeah yeah
yeah i'm a dancer um i'm not a dancer um
and she
knew that because she said are you sure
well tell us the way you answered the
question would be a giveaway are you a
dancer
yeah yeah dancing that thing you said
i do i do it every day yes
um i i went i went to the
audition and it was a room full of
dancers and they had their leotards on
and their
hair and buns and i had like sweatpants
and like running shoes on
i should not have been there you're like
showing up for the rocky audition yeah
i was like doing little stretches like
two-second quad stretches while they
have their leg up right there
um and i went into the room and and
i was terrified very nervous and the
woman was like okay well
this is a promo and you are going to be
a flame
so we want you to start out like crouch
down and
and kind of like do a turn they wanted
people to act like they were a flame
what was this ad for i don't know it was
like a promo for something flame broiled
burgers
we can't show you an actual flame so
we'll show a woman dancing
right that's very strange yeah yeah so i
i like got i like got down on the ground
and i like had my
hands over my face to be very you know
dramatic flame-like
very flame-like and i just it was like
three seconds i just basically
just like stood up and and just put my
arms out
and i like remembered the flame so i
went like that and then at the end i
just wanted to finish it off so i was
just like
i did it i did this is more a mushroom i
think than flame
i think flame i would do this if i was a
flame
what is that turning you on that's a
flame right there that's a wildfire
flame that's what i would do
i didn't do that i'd have gotten that
part i'd tell you right now
i'd have been in a leotard doing this i
never would have gotten this job
your life should get difficult yeah it
would have just all fallen apart for me